[Musique]
les petits enfants bonjour comme vous
vous en doutez mirabel et son frère
petit louis ont été très occupés
aujourd'hui ils sont allés avec leur
maman chercher de la nourriture pour
leurs jolis petits poissons rouges car
il est très gourmand et ne veut pas
manger n'importe quoi au loup rouge mais
finalement ils lui ont trouvé de la
délicieuse poissonnet la poisse honnête
roja pourrait bien goûter samoa hop la
pop à pau
[Musique]
tu vas bonjour nous y avoir mangé une
jolie petite maison le nom la mort avec
des cailloux et sam accord jamie bell
baignoire pour rendre son avis comment
vous ne lui avait pas mis des des
coquillages pour quoi faire
parce que les poissons saem les
coquillages dans tout le monde sait ça
attendez je vais voir dans ma poche là
dans ma mort au fond de ma poche oui
j'en ai ramené des très beaux de tahiti
à aller à la douce
bon vous allez me faire mal
là encore ce joyau mois moi je mets
encore ce petit verre voilà ça suffit
citant une source
on sait pas comment il s'appelle poisson
peut-être
[Musique]
donald mickey minnie en disant c'est un
achat d'or aux jo tu es bien dire mais
on dirait qu'il a sommeil ils pas tous
bons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je vais le faire la voilà c'est fait
au revoir les enfants dorment bien oscar
ono tobias car ce cas
[Musique]
et bien voilà ce joli petit poisson
rouge s'appelle oscars je suis sûr qu'il
dort déjà et que vous n'allez pas tarder
à faire comme lui
bonnut des enfants embrassez vos parents
est allé sagement vous coucher à demain
adobuzz
[Musique]